this is Vietnam right away what does
that be enough I think I'm gonna do well
in this area not so much this area I'd
say I don't know where anything is other
than Japan and China I have no
experience with Asian geography and I'm
Asian so please locate Laos Wow
come on Laos Laos Laos hold up I think
about down here right then here's some
yeah while I was there because that was
just screaming loud to me boom Wow no
[ __ ] it I'm going in Hey uh-huh
I don't you know what I didn't even look
down there Thailand Thailand that's one
of the fun ones
isn't this Thailand no nevermind it
looks like a freaking brain so I'm sure
dissected Thailand let's think about
what kind of foods they got this is
Thailand this is like oh I don't know I
don't know peanut stuff where's good
soil for peanuts oh my god I've been to
Thailand it's in the shape of this like
long weird tea doesn't it look like old
duck it does look like a duck quite
quite quick little duck quite quite I'm
gonna go for the duck it's this tent
teeny one god I knew it
dang it please locate Syria Syria boom I
know it's over here Syria I know her
there is a war there we should know this
would mean we got to know this one
where's Europe on this map the big one I
think is a country or body of water all
right let's go there that's a good call
I think like that too cuz that looks
like a poner
no it's at fam Syria look uh yeah oh we
were so yeah you know what I'm really
proud we went for the boner of a sugar
cone for the testicle no definitely
always go for the testicle yeah
Philippines oh that's an island right
welp I'm 1/8 Filipino so this one's
gonna hurt
I have a lot of Filipino friends you are
hoping uh okay don't put it down mate
you're part Filipino you don't know
where the Philippines are I'm part
Filipino so I've looked at it on a map a
bunch of times even though I've never
gone this guy looks fun yeah and then
the Philippines maybe it's all of this
yeah you know what I think it might be
this little cluster whoa
that was you well yes yeah of course we
had to know that too yeah huge Filipino
fanbase picture I showed him what was
probably the Philippines and he's like
yeah you know what it is I don't think
so maybe it's all of this you know Iran
Iran
piling on the guilt I get confused with
Iraq and her copy this one but this one
this one we should go like this way
that's Iran Iran I think it's this one
no wait it's this [ __ ] that might be
Iraq goddamn it
what is your heart say I think it's a
person reason if that's your heart go
for it always follow your heart this is
Iran I was gone Wow Bingle adesh
England - is near India because their
food is similar India I'm pretty sure
that's in so Bangladesh is either here
what about here Bangladesh is here it's
part of a jumble of other countries
okay so damn I don't know do you think
it's this one yeah I mean the only other
one a khabees here unless it's this one
it just is kind of like stuck in there
like when you bang someone that's
Bangladesh we're
oh crap co-packer a good job Oh what's
up what's up I will totally sell Ryan
down the river and the initial thought
that that was China's like well that's
China obviously I now deny that today